how many owners have really come out and
spoke on our behalf how many of these
college coaches have come out and spoke
on our behalf that ride these black
players in football
and basketball to where they're the
highest paid college coaches around the
country and their programs are
benefiting
not too many and to me their silence
speaks volumes
i'm tayla rooks and these are
conversations about defining
one's relationship to blackness and how
that defines their america
so when did you realize that being black
was different than being white i learned
early
being biracial born in san jose
i was you know as early as i can
remember i was amongst black
and mexican kids but i moved to
sacramento
at nine eight or nine and i went from
predominantly
mexican and black to all white schools
so in third grade um being new at this
school
i found out very early on that i was
black and it was because the kids
wouldn't let me play anything
couldn't play basketball with them
wouldn't let me play kickball with them
wouldn't let me build a football with
them
and instead of you know poor me
hug and console when i went home um you
know my dad said if they call you [ __ ]
fighter
so i learned in in third grade that you
know if kids were i didn't know it was
racial or racism at the time but if they
called me [ __ ] because that's what the
kids were calling me
to fight them so i learned fairly early
that
my skin color made some people just not
like me without even knowing me
how many fights did you get in oh i got
in so many fights that my mom had to
come work at my school
my mom came and worked as uh like a yard
duty
on her off time at my schools because it
was constant
and i would tell the school and and
nothing would really happen
you know so it got to a point where my
mom was just on campus during
the recess and during lunch time just to
kind of
somewhat keep me out of trouble but
somewhat keep kids away from me that
were you know harassing me
in what ways do you feel like you
yourself were treated differently maybe
not by
kids but just by the white people um in
the
town that you lived um that i was just
different you know like i said my
neighborhood what was multicultural we
had everything in my neighborhood but my
parents
early on made a point to put me in
better schools and better schools where
i was from that
met white schools you know so i never
understood why
you know i was so like why can't i go to
school with my friends in the
neighborhood
and all that kind of stuff and and i was
never allowed to
um and i guess it set me up
long term to just kind of be more
versatile and more of a chameleon and
even though
like i said i'm half italian my first
eight nine years i was never really
around white kids you know so to be
thrust into that position in third grade
um was a culture shock for me um
one and then two from the educational
side i went from
being going into third grade in san jose
moving and then being in third grade in
sacramento i got and i realized what the
educational system was like too because
i went from third grade there to
they had some of my classes back in the
kindergarten class so i'm this big old
billy madison type kid
because the schooling where i was at was
obviously below par
you know so i i learned very quickly at
a
about age nine that color and race
played a huge factor um in my life
you know you've mentioned you know being
biracial being half italian
and there's obviously you know black
people are not a monolith
everybody's experience is different just
like everybody's dna
is different not everybody's blackness
is the same being halfway
and being half black do you feel like
you had to choose um i never
chose and to be honest with you i never
really
fit in because as a biracial child
you're never wide enough and you're
never black enough
you know what i mean so i wasn't dark
enough and i had
this good hair um and then the with the
with the white kids i was i was darker
than them
and just a different complexion and
different mannerisms you know so i was
never
i never really had anywhere to run you
know now being biracial is more of the
norm and i think in the next 10 years 15
years everyone's going to be mixed up
somewhat but i was really old i was by
myself i was on an island
until i really got a chance and i think
through sports
once these kids once they were finally
tired of getting beat up they finally
allowed me to play with them and then
once they allowed me to play with them
and i was the best
you know football basketball baseball
kickball
through sports is what that allowed them
to get the chance to get to know me as a
person
um so that was kind of the turning point
and oddly enough i still have friends
from third grade
that not necessarily that i got into
fights with but there were actually some
of the first kids to kind of accept me
and allow me to kind of show who i was
through sports and
man almost 30 years later you know i'm
still friends with them yeah
now of course you know being black and
white you have lighter skin
um so i kind of want to talk to you
about colorism not just in the black
community but how white people
respond to colorism or lighter skinned
black people how do you think colorism
has maybe
affected your life and have you seen
people respond to you
differently because you maybe have more
european features you have lighter skin
um i don't think colorism has affected
me
as much as racism has racism has been
heavier although colorism does exist and
and definitely i feel like in our black
community and when i say
black i feel like these days if you have
a drop of black in you you're black
you know what i mean so i've learned
that 17
um 18 excuse me right before i was about
to graduate high school go to ucla 1998.
there was a situation at my high school
where my sister was a sophomore and
um a boy was calling her [ __ ] spitting
her hair
and i never ran into this kid and
finally one day she came to me
as my fourth period ended i was going
home for the day and told me this boy
called me a [ __ ] again and spit my
hair
so i went and happened to just see the
kid walking by so i did what a big
brother does
you know beat them up try to go to the
office and explain what happened and
they didn't believe me so keep this in
mind i'm the number one football player
number one basketball player everyone
knows i'm going to ucla
but here i'm in the midst of you know
kind of a racial situation
where my school doesn't believe me so to
this day i don't give a dollar back to
my high school because of this
particular incident
so anyway i get suspended for a week and
while i'm suspended my school was
vandalized by the kkk
so burnt down a bathroom vandalized
broken windows swastikas everywhere died
[ __ ]
and a mannequin hanging from the big
tree in front of my school with uh
with my football jersey on that said
[ __ ] so
i realized that seven or 18 that
even though i was very proud to be
biracial and italian and black that the
world looked at me as a black man
so it wasn't to answer your earlier
question i never really chose
the world shows for me you said
something i think
is important which is you know i was the
number one basketball player
number one football player but it didn't
matter
because i think a lot of times when we
are you know in the heat of these
racial movements people will say what do
you know you're this
you're that america has afforded you
these great things you don't even know
what it means to be
right like to have to be affected by
racism because that's not what your life
reflects
but they're not understanding that
whether you're a football player
basketball player famous person you're
still black at the end of the day
absolutely and i don't know if that is a
thing that registers like racism doesn't
have to do with your status it simply
has to do
with the color of your skin you know
having younger children i talked to them
about that
and my twins are
half black a quarter italian and a
quarter mexican
you know so they're very mixed and i'm
thankful from the standpoint of
everything i faced growing up that you
can't really tell what my kids are
and like i said in 2020 it's more of you
know biracial is is is around a lot more
than it was in the early 80s when i was
coming up as a child because it was you
know you were
black you were white you were asian
there wasn't really too much
mixing going on at that time so you know
i have conversations with my sons
because they're old enough to understand
stuff right now we talked about the
george floyd stuff and
simple stuff and and you know one of my
sons asked me like
you're trying to tell me that someone's
going to hate me just because it's
coloring my skin
and i said i hope not but it's
definitely a possibility you know so for
children to kind of grasp
that you know my kids aren't going to
grow up like i grew up food stamps
drug-filled environment abuse obviously
you know i've worked my butt off to to
put them in private schools and we live
behind gates
myself and their mom live behind gates
so they haven't
experienced it um and i hope they don't
but i'm sure at one point
um they will so i just kind of want them
to be prepared
you know what i mean i think we have to
start educating our kids at an early age
knowing that this is a this is a cult
world although i feel
now more than ever we're at a turning
point um with this stuff and
and things are starting to get done i
still really feel that that hate will
never go anywhere because it's a top
trait and there's still
too many people in this world that hate
and teach their children to hate so
you know children turn into adults that
hate so
i i'm very open uh with my kids when it
comes to
situations that they need to be aware of
and
and race is definitely one of them when
you're talking to your kids
how often do you stress or do you stress
that for them
to maybe succeed or be accepted they
have to be
excellent and the reason i ask that is
because i went into a talk
where lena waith was discussing her
movie queen and slim and there is a line
in the movie where
he's talking about how he wants to be
the best and she says why do black
people always have to be excellent
and i think a lot of that is because
like she said
we think we have to be excellent in
order to justify
the space that we take up whereas you
know
i don't think white people the majority
of white people say like you know
i have to be the best doctor they can
just be a doctor
you know or i have to be the best
teacher they can just they are afforded
the luxury of not having to be
exceptional at it
because they don't have to explain to
people why they are where they are
well i just think the reason why that
happens is because you know if we're
lucky enough to get into these fields or
these professions we
don't get a chance to make mistakes so
to speak you know what i mean so
a person a white person could be very
comfortable being a doctor lawyer
whatever situation
and if you mess up you're most likely
gonna get another chance and i compare
this
really in sports and with blackhead
coaches
having to really be careful picking
their jobs because most of the time
where there's a
there's a coaching change it's because
it's a bad team so a white coach can go
in there
and be subpar and get fired and get
another job
but a black coach um you know you don't
get too many chances
i think white people historically have
been afforded the opportunity to
fail up and black people just do not get
to fail
up they only get to fail and more than
that
it's like when one black person fails
it's like all the black people failed
right
yeah it's it's all completely completely
grouped together but when you talk about
you know
how certain like white coats have been
able to bounce around even if they're
losing they get new jobs
when we talk about diversity in sports
or diversity in any workplace
it isn't simply so that you can have
these numbers to check out that you have
a person of color
it actually really does improve the
place that you work because
maybe the reason none of these teams are
getting better is because you're
continuing to hire the same people
hiring different people would improve it
you know so that's i know we can cross
over we're just not giving
the the opportunity to cross over but
let me ask you
what is it like for young
black coming up in a space like this is
that has
predominantly been white women in your
position or white men in your position
that are doing these
um this kind of stuff that you're doing
yeah i mean
you know i always say i take a lot of
pride in the fact that i am a black
woman who
looks black and i say that because
growing up when i was looking at any
woman on tv specifically covering
sports they were white blonde hair
and if they weren't white or blonde and
they were black they had
long hair little noses very light skin
it was everybody on tv was almost
tailored to make
white people comfortable um
and i take a lot of pride and
responsibility in being in this space
and talking a lot about black people
both for black people and two black
people because i think it's important
and i wish it's something that i always
had
when i was growing up but my experience
is always going to be different
than any man's black or white and
definitely different than any
white woman but i find a lot of strength
in that you know i tell people all the
time i think one of the biggest
advantages that i have as an
interviewer is that i'm a woman and that
i'm black
i think athletes just inherently feel
more comfortable
talking to someone who looks like them
do you find that
like you said you found it to be a
strength but can it also be a negative
point of view because one you're a woman
in sports and then two you're a black
woman in sports
so although you've turned it into a
strength
was it ever a hindrance in your process
or do you know any of your colleagues
who were in the same position where
it's it's held them back for those two
reasons that you turned into strengths
yeah for sure i mean you know i'm very
close with carrie i'm friends with raz
maria we talk about these things all of
the time
i would say the hindrance hasn't
necessarily come
from being black as much as it has come
from the perception of black people or
black women
i think people over sexualize
black women and they have historically
it doesn't matter what we're doing we
become over-sexualized
um and it
we are the only people that will be
talking to a person or doing interview
and somebody says
oh like they'd be cute together or ooh
were they dating
simply because we're two black people
and black women
it doesn't matter what i wear i could be
wearing a turtleneck
and slacks and the conversation is about
what i look like and that is because we
over sexualize black women and i mean
that
about white men and black men
that is something that i think black men
have to be a bit better at
um is seeing black women as whole women
and not just seeing them and their
relationship to them
if that makes sense i never thought
about it from that point of view i've
never looked at it and made those
assumptions but
you know being friends with carrie you
know these are some of the conversations
we have too and she tells me you know
that
i'm wearing a simple dress with my legs
out and all of a sudden i'm too sexy
but you know my counter same thing and
just because she doesn't have as much
sun on her
on her body it's it's not a problem yeah
yeah
absolutely and i i also think
it's so that conversation is so layered
but i think black women are left out of
a lot of
conversations and i think brianna taylor
is a perfect example of that
that she has been lost in a lot of ways
in this movement
and i'm glad that now you know everybody
is calling for her murderers to be
arrested and maybe
i have the brianna law that's passed
because of her but
me with piss me i'm not to cut you off
but how do you have a law
for her now but haven't arrested the
cops that makes no sense
those those don't go together yeah
you're admitting there was some type of
wrongdoing
but you haven't arrested however there's
no consequence to the wrongdoers and i
just think that's crazy
police report which is insane but go
ahead
yeah no yeah it's the brianna taylor
thing is just so sad and
you know i anytime i'm on my phone and i
see you know
black men dying it hurts but to see
someone who
absolutely could be you like brianna
taylor is me she's my friend she is a
black woman who was working and was just
in her apartment um and i think that
that hit a lot of us differently and i
think black women just want to continue
to
to be supported the way that black women
support black men
i hear you i hear you no like nobody
goes harder for black men
than black it if ever listen to um
tupac's song called white man's world
off the machiavelli album it says that
you know black women
aren't in dangerous speech so you guys
have the toughest job in this world
you know what i mean to just just exist
let alone
elevate yourself you know like i said
because you're behind the eight ball
twice
you know you're coming you're black and
don't be a lesbian
you know what i mean so then all three
things are really stacked against you so
i take pride in seeing
women like you and carrie and lena and
ava and all these women
you know exceed expectations because
although they're killing us and doing
all this stuff
i still feel it's a lot harder for black
women to climb
the ladder uh so to speak than it is for
for black men yeah no i totally agree
um you touched on something in there
though that i want to get your opinion
on
what do you think or how would you
describe
is the black athlete's relationship with
the media
um seeing it from you as an athlete and
now you
as a medium i don't want it because it's
it's
i don't want it i'm not even going to
make that analogy because it's not the
right time
they just don't trust them you know what
i mean and i think that's the reason why
myself and stephen jackson have been
able to
succeed not only on espn and fox but
on our podcast all the smoke because
there's no hidden agendas
we're not looking for click bait we
genuinely want to have a conversation
with you and humanize you and show the
world the other side of you
you mentioned jack and i just want to
give you a chance to talk about maybe
how you have been moved by him during
this time
inspired by him during this time because
i think for so many of us
it's just it has been
something in this movement that has been
beautiful
and i think we've needed to hold on to
some things that are beautiful
yes um and he's just he's had some
really beautiful moments that that
inspired us all
um you know just as a brother of mine
he's i i couldn't have been more prouder
than
of him you know jack just kind of
there was a misconception of who he was
because the brawl at um
against detroit in in in the mid 2000s
and i think he was labeled such as you
know as i was able throughout my career
as a thug as a problem maker
um you know someone you can't work with
but you know our teammates will tell the
world
everything about that you know we were
always labeled as great teammates they
would always have our backs so to see
his transition
one shedding his old image and
reputation but then two stepping in to
quote unquote the fire with this with
this
george floyd situation it like he said
it wasn't something he planned it wasn't
something he wanted but it was something
that was put on his plate and i think
he's done a tremendous job of
handling what's come with that you know
i've been in this social justice space
for maybe about four or five years i did
the stephon clark stuff up north in
sacramento my hometown
and even though i'm i'm doing stuff
right and speaking on the behalf of the
people who don't have a voice
you're still going to take a lot of
criticism from people and
um you know that's something that jack
is is getting now you know so we're
talking here and there
i know his plate is full but you know i
just hit him every once in a while just
to remind the man of how proud i am of
him how much i love him and to really
take care of himself
you know what i mean because this just
all this negativity and i'm sure you
felt it too it just
it's disheartening and it sucks the life
out of you you know what i mean in him
to be on the front line
still in minnesota nearly two weeks
later
um i just tell him you know to protect
his essence protect his his
his mental health make sure he gets rest
make sure he's taking time for him
because
you know all this negativity is not good
for anybody you know but he's doing it
for a great reason but there's still a
lot of push back
and you see a lot of people talking
negative about him and his family now
and calling him an opportunist and all
this kind of stuff but at the end of the
day
he's doing what's right and he's a part
and he's going we look back on this in
20 or 30 years jack is going to be one
of the main people
that people think about as far as
turning this movement
you know there's obviously george floyd
wasn't the first and he won't be the
last
but i think for the first time in 400
years the world hears us
and it's because this man was executed
in front of us and the world saw
um so that that was the tipping point
finally and although i never
and you probably feel the same way i
didn't agree with the looting and
stealing stuff and burning stuff but at
the same time
they've always had a problem with every
way we've protested you know what i mean
you got to do what you got to do at some
point marches we
took a knee and was blackballed so you
know enough was enough and and there
were some casualties of wars and that
was small businesses and stuff but
for the first time they hear us now and
i think jack's platform brought a lot of
light to that and obviously there was
the sean king's and other athletes and
other actors but i think
stephen's connection to george floyd
made that made it that much more special
that he was a part of it and someone
that's leading the movement forward
we talk about the movement and the
movement is now
touching a lot of different areas i had
just reported
that i had been talking to multiple nba
players and they said that
a couple days ago there was a call with
about 50 of them talking about what they
could do
and tonight they plan on having a call
with a much larger number figuring out
what they want to do um have you been
privy to those calls
and what is kind of the chatter i know
you talked a little bit about it
i i don't really know what's going on in
in those conversations
i've had conversations with a couple
guys that were kind of like
you know do we play in in the midst of
all this in the midst of the pandemic
um you know but i really feel like right
now more than ever
the black voice is heard but the black
athlete voice has never been stronger
and may never be stronger
you know so whatever they do and that
athlete in me obviously doesn't want to
see them sit out
i miss basketball as much as everyone
else does as much as they do
and i want to see it get back to the
court but at the same time
being able to watch this black ball
documentary of my clipper team um from
2014
being in the moment obviously as players
and feeling like we had a chance to win
a championship
we wanted to play because we didn't know
what the outcome of sitting out was but
we also didn't know the magnitude and
the message it would have said if we did
sit out
you know so i hope that everyone got a
chance to see that and kind of learn
because me looking at it six years ago
removed being six years removed i would
have urged my team to sit out
you know i was the one that came up with
the idea of what to do as far as the
jerseys and flip and all this kind of
stuff and we did have conversations
about not playing and golden state was
on board with us as well but
we did there was too much unknown but i
think now we're at a point where
like i said our voice has never been
stronger um although i don't want them
to sit i would understand if
if they sat out a game or or did
something
to really let everyone know that this is
not okay we're unified
and we need to be heard so to get back
to your point i haven't been on those
conversations and i and i don't really
pry
i'm someone i'm a quote unquote og now
so people would just randomly reach out
to me kind of ask me
my what i think of my thoughts so i have
spoke to a few players on that on that
front and i don't preach i don't tell
them to sit out i just kind of give them
the whole magnitude of the situation and
understanding whatever you guys do
it's going to be powerful so just make
sure you're united in that movement
what would you say to adam silver
if he asked you the best way
to address racism
that's a good question i think all the
teams
should start a fund you know and and
and really and individual funds for
their cities
and and look to help their communities
not just put out psas or
cheap pr things of of guys saying stuff
because
you know how most of the stuff goes this
talked about and then
a couple weeks later we get back to real
life and kind of forget about it i would
love to see each team start some sort of
fund
that is community based in their city
and it can go to a number of different
things whatever that team
feels is lacking in their minority in
the minority
culture of their cities um you know i
had a phone call
with um rob polinka maybe
two weeks ago out of the blue
and he kind of just hit me up like hey
matt hut you know we're looking
for things to do as a as the lakers you
know as a
as a uh as an organization to really
unite
and be a part of this movement and being
an effective part of this movement and
it kind of took me off guard i'm like
the lakers are calling me to ask you i
mean so
i told them i was like man that's a
heavy question i got zooms and i got my
kids get me to the end of the day and
i'll send you some ideas so i sent
them some ideas but the first thing i
said was earlier is just like this can't
be just a pr move to save face
you know i mean this can't just be let
me let me put a laker statement out let
the lakers know you're with us
to me either don't say nothing if you
get in you got to really get
in you got to be entrenched there's
things you can do
and i gave them a list of things they
can do and i'm going to probably talk to
them this week to kind of touch base and
see what they decided but
you know to me you got to be all the way
in and it seemed that the nba is so
progressive and we usually are
the ones that are first to do stuff and
and people follow
i would just love to see each team start
a fun because you know these
organizations are making so much money
off these players and all the players
have tremendous contracts
you got to think of our our contracts
are so well how much are the owners
making
you know if they're able to pay steph
and lebron and these guys 200 million
dollars a year
excuse me during the million dollar
contracts imagine how much money
these teams are making so you start
these funds and consistently doing stuff
don't give me a one-time donation make
it
make it a you know make this a
cornerstone of your franchise
make it a once a year huge donation but
let's build something from here and
that's what i was trying to tell the
lakers you guys do something trend
setting or
or groundbreaking you guys are the
lakers so i think other teams are going
to fall in line not only in basketball
but professional sports across the board
so
it's going to be interesting i've always
been a fan of
adam silver and his outside the box
thinking
but i think the nba is so progressive it
has to be something that's heartfelt
that's meaningful that won't just go
away
you know once we're done talking about
george floyd yeah and you're right the
nba is so progressive probably the most
progressive
of the leagues i think adam silver is a
fantastic leader and the things that he
has done
for the league you however were in the
thick
of a scandal with the league when
everybody found out that
you know sterling was racist right
but i guess and i mean symbolically
how many if any donald sterlings
still exist in nba front offices
a lot a lot and not only an nba in the
nfl i know for sure
you know what i mean so it's just and i
don't you don't want to give names but
there's that that good old boy
group of owners that were oil or real
estate guys these guys are in their
you know 70s late 60s 70s and up
and that's just how they were raised and
how they were brought up
you know what i mean and they look at
players as
i didn't want to use the word slave
that's harsh but just these are my like
a kind of a plantation view or mentality
like these are my guys i pay them i
i like donald sterling said i get them
cars i get them food i get them houses
he wasn't the only one to think like
that he's just the only one dumb enough
to get caught
but i guarantee there's owners in these
leagues
and in particular if you look at it how
many owners have really came out and
spoke
on behalf of us and not a generic
like roger goodell read off the thing
and still didn't even address the cap
situation
but how many owners have really come out
of the spoke on our behalf
how many of these college coaches have
come out and spoke on our behalf that
ride these black players in football and
basketball to where they're the highest
paid college coaches around the country
and their programs are benefiting
not too many and to me their silence
speaks volumes
you know i mean you want to go into our
house as college players and
i'm going to take care of your son i'm
going to do whatever he's gonna love it
in lexington and he's gonna love it in
oklahoma or he's gonna love it at lsu
but now when when the you know the [ __ ]
quote unquote really hits the fan
you're getting these generic
you know statements that pr people wrote
for these coaches to read and i just
wish it would be more heartfelt and you
have that same energy
when you're trying to recruit us to win
national championships and now you that
you have for us that
when our backs are against the wall and
we're in this fire yeah
and i'm not asking you to name names
when i ask you the question you said for
sure
are there like instances in your head
that
make you sure you know that there are
these people that still exist
yes i've seen situations that have
happened personally to me
i've i've been around other owners i've
played for several teams i've talked to
different
um players about situations and and
and not only in basketball in football
and
it's just a kind of an unspoken thing
you know but
it's definitely still there it's
definitely prevalent
and you know i think the fact that they
had to make the rooney rule in the nfl
which is crazy to think that you had to
make a rule that teams would
at least interview one minority person
for a management jobs
tells you their train of thought and in
the lines that they're thinking because
most of the time they're just looking
over us or not even getting up giving us
an opportunity
you know for those so some people say
you know those jobs aren't racially
filled it's just the best man gets the
job and
for the most part that's true but the
best black candidates aren't even
getting a chance
they start even getting a chance to
interview you know so i'm sure you
probably hired the best
white person you felt fit the job but
it's because you didn't give any black
people a chance to even
interview for the job i was watching an
interview that you did with vlad
and you had this quote you said to me
there will always be racism
racism is something that's taught we
have to learn to maneuver within that
so my question is that what you still
believe and if so
how do we win if
racism will always exist
i think it's always going to exist and i
still do agree with that but i think
we're to a point now where
we need more white allies and we're
starting to gain those and i think the
one thing we saw through these
protests and rallies and rights whatever
you you want to call it
we had every every race out there you
know every skin color
every religion everyone came together
you know what i mean so i think we need
more people that are for us and with us
and and
and have an open mind because we used to
give people a pass saying
well you know they didn't grow up that
way or they're white or this is and
that's why they don't understand this
and that used to be an
okay past that people get but now it's
not okay you know now you have to have
an
understanding and i think people are
starting to do that so
i just feel like we need to call people
on racism
people need to be fired from their jobs
people need to be publicly embarrassed
the world needs to know that
you know your fedex driver that is
delivering your packages you know
did a protest the other day with a man a
knee on a man's neck talking about
you know f george floyd black lives
don't matter only white lives matter
you know so i think more than ever you
know
the black culture quote unquote wants to
be on this this cancel culture
but to be honest because cancer culture
now more than ever is going to be real
because we're getting people on camera
who are just blatantly showing who they
are
in their racism and before you know it
their face is circling and their names
circling and then they're fired
you know so i when i say i think we're
going to have to work
within that i think we just need to
continue to have that you know we always
got criticized oh you always want to
bring race in it why do you always want
to pull the race card because race plays
a big part in our everyday life
in everything and people finally see
that now so
like i said it's a talk thing i
hopefully it's going to open up enough
eyes for parents to start teaching love
because your kid is going to you know i
like i had a conversation with my twins
about the george floyd situation and i
asked them
is hate taught are you born with it
and they both hesitated and they're like
top
i'm like you're absolutely right just
like you can teach love and then they
have a i have an 18 month old too so
then one of my son's like we're gonna
have to
teach ashton how to love you know and
it's really
that simple you know i mean these kids
are sponges so you're they're gonna
they're gonna learn and be whatever you
feed them you know so if you're teaching
them love
they're gonna have a better chance so
like i said i still think there's
too many people in this world that hate
for no reason if you ask to
a kkk member or a white person like why
don't you like black people they
couldn't give you no real answer
they're give you a stereotypical answer
one of them rob
my cousin or they do this or they're on
welfare they can't give you no real
answer so they're just hating
to hate so i hope this movement changes
some of that but i'm not naive enough to
think it's just going to disappear so
i think we're just going to have to
learn to maneuver within it but
more white people are going to have to
start calling people on this stuff just
like bad cops are going to start having
to call bad cops on their stuff i just
think the more we
expose this hate it'll eventually
you know not go away but hopefully
shrink
um i'm ending every interview in this
series with this question
and that's that words mean different
things to different people
matt how do you define america
a gift and a curse um i think that
we're very lucky in some aspects to be
here
and and and um live this quote-unquote
dream
because although it's been tough for me
i've been able to live a dream i faced a
ton of racism in my 40 years but
if i sit back and look at the big
picture i played 14 years of the nba
made a lot of money i have a beautiful
family and i'm thriving in business
and doing things to try to help other
people but at the same time
i was a lucky one you know we both beat
the odds to be able to do what you're
doing to be able to do what i'm doing we
beat the odds so
we realize that some of our people
aren't as lucky and that's where i say
it's a curse because we've
i've had personal friends and we've seen
people that we don't even know but grown
fond of lose their life because it's the
color of their skin so
it definitely means that flag means
something different to most black people
america means something different than
most black people
but i think at the end of the day we are
lucky to an extent
and i think now more than ever our
voices are going to be heard and we have
a chance
to change what america means and what
that flag means for our children
our grandchildren and generations to
come
no that was beautiful thank you so much
matt no problem thanks for having me
good luck
[Music]
you